Destin's about being a super powerful
hero set loose in a really beautiful
world the first time I fired my super I
was like screaming I'm so badass right
now I'm playing games for 30 years that
I've never experienced bad destiny is
about playing with your friends my best
moments are with other players the first
time I beat both of class I know who was
there with me and that just makes it
fuel so much more rich bungees always
been at the forefront of exploring new
ways to bring our games to our players
we are now our own publisher did you
know this in the stadia who get to be
the tip of the spear with something
that's new our push now is to remove all
the barriers that we have to playing
destiny whenever wherever with whomever
you want we're allowing players to have
access to all of it all of our planets
all the cooperative strikes all the
competitive modes gambit raids it's all
there for players to jump in and have
fun with Chado Keita
is the next chapter in the destiny story
it's a pretty haunting tale there are
these nightmares that are walking the
moon and you'll have to find a way to
conquer these nightmares and face your
fears we have a lot to do with this
material we're not done yet we now are
in control of our own destiny
behind us we have an incredible
community and with stadia I think we're
gonna open up an entirely new
opportunity for players to come in and
play with their friends from around the
world
you
looking to the future always brings us
back
to the past can you feel them I can
still hear their voices their endless
torment reshapes are me nightmares now
stalk the surface walking shadows
seeking vengeance our old fears may rise
again
and in the dark below something wicked
has awakened we must bring an end to
this suffering one way
or another
[Music]